hi I'm Matt Welch I met Freedom Fest in
Las Vegas and I am honored to be joined
by the great David Bose executive vice
president of the Cato Institute David
thank you for joining us thank you
you've done some interesting work and
Kato is done over the years about the
libertarian votes the block of people
who are voting in whether they
self-identify his libertarian they trend
towards that have you done any recent
work on that how big do you perceive the
libertarian block is and where are their
heads at as we approach the twenty
twelve election well people ask me
sometimes how many libertarians are
there in America I can give you any
number ranging from like a hundred
thousand to fifty nine percent of the
public but the best numbers we think
David Kirby and I and the work we did in
two papers is that if you ask people
three values questions and you take the
people who give libertarian answers to
all three then you get somewhere around
fifteen percent of the electorate they
are questions like is the government
doing too much or should it do more to
solve social problems should the
government be promoting traditional
values or should it stay out of
promoting any kind of values and I think
there's a third one that also is sorted
about size of government intervention
and now where do you see that going I
mean it's there we don't have recent
data we know that they swung back
against the obama pelosi read democrats
in 2008 and we argued in our paper the
libertarian vote in the age of obama
that libertarians are a leading
indicator of where independents are
going they turned against bush and the
republicans earlier than the other
independence did they turned against the
Pelosi Congress earlier than other
independence did in 2010 I haven't seen
data on how libertarians voted but we
know in 2008 they swung back toward the
Republicans or I like to thank against
the Democrats and in 2010 with the tea
party voting and everything I can only
imagine that they did vote more strongly
that way so I mean there's a lot of
pressure or a lot of discussion
particularly in the wake of you
Obamacare decision which was a 5-4
decision a lot of Republicans for people
who want libertarians to play nice with
Republicans are using the Supreme Court
card now more than ever you're a
Virginia residents from not mistaken so
is this the year that libertarians need
to come home to the Republican Party
where do you see that kind of pressure
that dynamic going any year that the
electoral votes of Virginia are decided
by one vote it is very important for me
to get out and vote since that will
never happen I take these your vote is
important with a grain of salt and my
own attitude toward voting tends to be
is it better to vote for what you don't
want and get it or vote for what you
want and not get it so the Supreme Court
is certainly a factor that ought to be
considered if you want more judges like
John Paul Stevens David Souter and John
Roberts than you would certainly want to
vote Republican in theory you might
assume you have more chance of getting
judges like Scalia and Thomas from a
Republican than you do from a Democrat
but let's remember there are First
Amendment issues there are issues of
civil liberties there are issues of the
Patriot Act surveillance and so on where
as a libertarian I don't really want
Republican judges in charge so i think
the Supreme Court is a mixed bag just as
policy in general is speaking of which
you had a great piece of things to
having him post recently talking about
well you know Obama really has things on
this record that he should be run on and
be proud of sort of a sardonically walk
us through some of the kind of non
economic reasons why libertarians should
be outraged at Obama's record well
that's right it's pretty tough for him
to run on the economy so I was trying to
say hey what can he run on well he's
done more drone strikes than any
president in history he's deported more
illegal immigrants than any president in
history he's held more fundraisers than
any incumbent president running for
reelection a lot of things like that
that might concern progressives more
medical marijuana raids than any
president in history so in that sense he
has a lot to boast about and yet I don't
really hear him boasting about most
kaito just came out of about nine months
of a pretty public and unpleasant battle
between some of the founding sort of
members or influential people about the
governance structure and whatever's
basically edgren versus the koch
brothers it was resolved a few weeks ago
and now john allison from BB&T the bank
and is a great libertarian of the zone
is now the head of it for a couple of
years kato change tell us what we can
think or know about kato in the future
in the wake of this which has now been
set well what happened was charles koch
thought this old document essentially
made him and his brother the owners of
the cato institute they filed suit it
wasn't just add crane it was pretty much
the entire staff and the entire board of
directors who resisted that a settlement
was then reached which involves ed crane
the co-founder and 35 years CEO retiring
somewhat earlier than he would have and
being replaced by john allison that
hasn't happened yet it'll happen in the
fall but it means we dissolve the
shareholder agreement that precipitated
right look crisis so from now on the
board of directors is clearly in control
of the Cato Institute and I think that
means we will stay on the same clear
libertarian keel that we have been John
alison has not yet been directly
involved he hasn't become CEO yet and so
I can't say how's life different what I
can say is he's one of the great
entrepreneurs of the past 20 years he
took BB&T from a small regional bank to
the tenth largest financial institution
in the country he has strong views about
management yes strong views about
liberty and individual rights he
strongly influenced by ein r and as many
of us are and so we're looking forward
to seeing what he might do and he's like
it he said it's a two-year thing no it
was a little confusion about that he's
the CEO he's a CEO as long as he and the
board are happy with that and there's no
term limit on it ed crane will remain
involved as a consultant and with our
fundraising and all of that so he'll
still be around too but John Allison
will become the CEO that's great thank
you for the update on that and thank you
thanks for joining us for recent TV with
David Bose I'm Matt Welch